[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi avec un focus sur les
métiers de la sécurité
sans oublier notre volet consacré à la
formation sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire
nous avons poussé les porsche de la
police municipale d'elancourt une
trentaine de fonctionnaires territoriaux
assurent des missions de prévention et
de répression et veille à la protection
du cadre de vie d elancourt trois
priorités au secours pour les
sapeurs-pompiers de montigny le
bretonneux accident de la circulation
incendiés mais aussi secours aux animaux
vous en saurez plus sur ce métier qui
fait rêver les plus jeunes
enfin si vous souhaitez devenir agent de
sécurité sachez que des formations
existent notamment avec le greta des
civils
florent salon conseillère en formation
continue nous en dira plus sur ces
formations destinées aux adultes ils
portent un uniforme et assure la
sécurité et le maintien de l'ordre
public dans vos communes
focus sur la police municipale nous nous
sommes rendus à elancourt elancourt qui
fait partie des quinze communes des
yvelines à avoir armé sa police
reportage nous sommes devant la police
municipale d'elancourt ici une trentaine
d'agents assurent des missions de
sécurité et de prévention cas brigades
sont chargés de protéger le cadre de vie
des élans courtois
christophe des canaux ski bonjour à
bonjour vous êtes le responsable de la
police municipale d'elancourt alors
cette pièce on nous nous trouvons c'est
le centre de supervision urbaine de la
ville d'elancourt
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer à
quoi il sert dans le cadre de la
protection
de la commune notamment des administrés
la pomme est encore a fait le choix de
se doter de caméras on a l'équivalent
d'une soixantaine de caméras à l'heure
actuelle sur le commerce en concernant
le métier de policier municipal
quels sont les les critères pour être un
bon policier municipal là-bas il faut
savoir observer faut savoir écouter
prendre le temps aussi parce qu'on reste
pas une police de proximité
donc il faut prendre le temps aussi de
d'écouter ce que les personnes ou les
administrés à maudire il faut qu'on soit
présent sur la voie publique
il faut qu'on soit lui c'est aussi la
demande de cautionnement est ce qu'on
soit présent du tout soit lui on va sur
et la population jean françois marteau
bonjour bonjour vous êtes brigadier sa
ferme an et demi que vous travaillez à
la police municipale d'elancourt et vous
avez une spécialité
en effet je suis mbt pays c'est-à-dire
moniteur bâton et techniques
professionnels d'intervention
ça consiste en quoi ça consiste à
pouvoir entraîner
tous les agents de police même manière
uniforme
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour fait ce métier alors moi
j'ai un parcours où j'ai intégré la
gendarmerie en 2005
donc pendant cinq ans j'ai été gendarme
adjoint volontaire à l'issue de ces cinq
ans donc j'ai décidé d'intégrer la
police municipale donc en 2010 j'ai
commencé par une autre ville dans les
yvelines et depuis 2013 sur la commune
d'el en cours alors les missions
principales donc déjà c'est un rôle de
proximité auprès de la population
donc on est très attaché est au service
des élans courtois pour répondre aux
problématiques quotidiennes des actes de
petite délinquance du tapage donc on est
très présent sur la voie publique
on est beaucoup présent sur les
quartiers aussi on essaie de se montrer
pour rassurer la population voit vous
êtes vous êtes armé sk pas quand même
avait des risques
bien sûr on est confronté à la violence
tous les jours que ce soit verbale ou
même physique donc avec ces dernières
années on se rend compte que
l'équipement nous a évolué du fait que
les comportements des gens aussi hanté
évolué donc oui il ya une notion de
risque après on essaye nous de faire le
maximum pour prévenir de ces risques on
s'entraîne de façon hebdomadaire
[Musique]
aussi portent l'uniforme et assure des
missions de sécurité je vous propose de
prendre la direction du centre de
secours principal des sapeurs-pompiers
de montigny le bretonneux il en existe
huit dans les yvelines pompiers un
métier qui inspire respect admiration un
métier dont les missions sont d'ailleurs
diverses comme vous allez le voir à
travers ce reportage
nous sommes au centre d'incendié et de
secours des sapeurs-pompiers de montigny
le bretonneux ici sont confiés
professionnels et volontaires oeuvrent
chaque jour pour notre sécurité notre
protection
[Musique]
philippe augé bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le commandant de ce centre de secours
principal des sapeurs pompiers
ici la caserne de montigny intervient
sur qu'elle a sur quels secteurs alors
le son de secours principal de montigny
intervient sur les communes de montigny
le bretonneux de trappes et une partie
des communes de guyancourt elancourt le
mesnil saint denis et la verrière alors
sur quel type de mission à vous êtes
appelés principalement nous avons
réalisé en 2017 environ 6800 sortie de
secours 75% de ses sorties de secours
sont relatives à la mission de secours à
personnes 10% sont relatives aux
incendies qui je le précise est une
mission exclusive du service incendie 9%
pour des accidents la circulation et le
reste ce sont des interventions diverses
ou des interventions relatives aux
risques technologiques
quand même une bonne condition physique
j'imagine alors pour ans très bien
évidemment il faut répondre à un certain
nombre de critères physiques et sportifs
et puis ensuite c'est la formation une
formation initiale puis des formations
de maintien des acquis qui vont
permettre aux sapeurs-pompiers de rester
opérationnel pendant toute leur carrière
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le centre de traitement
des alertes avec le lieutenant jean
pierre coly le bonjour un plongeon alors
est ce que pourrait nous expliquer en
quoi consiste ce lieu donc c'est le
centre de traitement des alertes du sud
du département
donc c'est ici qu'ils arrivent tous les
appels 18 et 112 donc ça en journée un
peu près 400 appels par jour et qui est
donc derrière il ya eu à peu près une
centaine d'interventions qui découlent
de ces 400 appels alors vous faites ce
métier depuis pendant longtemps elle a
une depuis 39 ans je suis rentré comme
sapeur pompier volontaire à l'âge de 16
ans j'ai suivi un peu la fibre
paternelle puisque mon père était chef
de centre volontaire alors vous êtes
sapeurs pompiers vous avez quand même
une spécialité ce copain peux nous en
parler oui eh bien je suis je fais
partie du groupe animalier donc j'en ai
une petite bébête qui est en pension
dans mon bureau
donc je fais partie s'est spécialisée
depuis depuis une vingtaine d'années une
spécialité qui intervient à peu près 150
à 200 fois dans l'année
on vient en complément des primes aux
intervenants qui sont déjà sur place et
qui n'ont pas les capacités et qui n'ont
pas le matériel pour intervenir sur les
animaux et donc on vient en complément
on peut parler de vocation pour ce
métier oui parce que la preuve en est
c'est que mon fils est mal aimé aussi
sapeur-pompier
donc ça va de génération en génération
donc oui je pense que c'est une vocation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous venez de découvrir deux
exemples de métiers liés à la sécurité
voici ce qu'il faut retenir
si vous souhaitez vous lancer dans une
carrière de policier municipal vous
devez passer un concours de la fonction
publique territoriale en débutant comme
brigadier vous toucher un salaire
d'environ 1400 euros net minimum plus
des primes un salaire bien sûr qui peut
varier selon les communes évolution
possible dans ce métier directeur de la
police municipale la qualité
indispensable avoir le sens du service
public
deuxième métier que vous avez pu
découvrir sapeurs pompiers
professionnels pour l'exercer il faut
passer un concours vous toucherez
l'équivalent du smic en début de
carrière évolutions possibles commandant
d'un centre de secours principal
le petit plus pour durer dans ce métier
avoir une bonne condition physique
surveille les centres commerciaux les
gares ou encore les aéroports les agents
de sécurité assure la protection des
biens et des pains et des personnes un
métier qui nécessite une formation comme
nous allons le voir avec notre invité
florence à l'oncle bonsoir dans ce vous
êtes conseiller en formation continue au
greta des yvelines deux mots justement
sur le greta qu'est ce que c'est alors
les greta sur les structures de
formation continue pour adultes de
l'éducation nationale donc à ce titre il
exerce une mission de service public ce
qui est un gage de sérieux et en même
temps ils appartiennent à un réseau qui
est labellisé en termes de qualité on a
un greta par département greta veux dire
c'est un mot un peu obscur mais en fait
qui veut dire groupement
d'établissements tout simplement parce
qu'on s'appuie pour dispenser ces
formations sur les lycées professionnels
et sur les formateurs qui sont attachés
à exclusivement parce qu'on peut aussi
envisager des formations en entreprise
met donc ainsi on peut dire que chaque
habitant des yvelines à une formation
professionnelle pour adultes pas très
loin de chez lui
s'ils habitent près d'un lycée
professionnel parmi ces formations donc
les métiers de la sécurité j'imagine que
c'est une formation théorique mais aussi
pratique
exactement
alors le greta des yvelines dispense des
formations dans des domaines extrêmement
variés qui vont du bâtiment en passant
par la restauration l'informatique
l'anglais et nous avons notamment un
domaine qui est celui de la sécurité et
donc d une formation ans et ap d'agents
de sécurité qui est d'ailleurs précédée
par ce qu'on appelle un accès à la
qualification ce que sont des formations
qui sont financés par la région
ile-de-france et le fonds social
européen et donc c'est une formation qui
effectivement comporte un volet
d'enseignement général donc avec des
matières comme le français mais maladie
sont géo et un volet professionnel et en
même temps donc on il ya une alternance
entre les périodes de on va dire
théorique bien que ce terme ne soit pas
tout à fait conforme à la réalité dans
la mesure où comme nos stagiaires sont
sur des plateaux techniques ils sont
amenés à faire des exercices pratiques
on a donc une période d'immersion en
entreprise de dix semaines
quel est le profil de ces personnes qui
suivent cette formation agent de
sécurité alors ce qui est frappant c'est
qu'on a très peu de femmes
on a une ou deux femmes au maximum par
promotion ce qui correspond à l'image
véhiculée par ces métiers dans l'opinion
publique à savoir un métier assez
physique ce qui ce qui ne correspond
plus à la réalité enfin je sais que je
ne sais pas si ça a correspond des en
totalement à la réalité
on a plutôt maintenant
donc qu il y aurait justement une
possibilité pour pour des femmes
justement de s'engager dans cette fin et
beaucoup de personnes en reconversion
professionnelle
un dernier mot sur le secteur des
métiers de la sécurité dans les yvelines
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
secteur porteur
oui alors c'est un secteur très porteur
notamment donc pour des gens qui sont
peu ou enfin pas ou peu qualifiés et
c'est surtout un secteur qui a connu une
petite baisse en 2008 mais qui depuis
2015 est un secteur vraiment en pleine
expansion c'est le quatrième secteur où
les besoins en main d'oeuvre sont les
plus importants pourquoi ce qu'il ya
deux raisons
il ya d'abord le contexte depuis 2015
malheureusement des attentats et d'autre
part une volonté politique très nette de
nouer un partenariat entre les forces de
sécurité publiques et privées
merci florence alan gold être intervenu
sur notre plateau je rappelle vous êtes
conseillère en formation continue au
greta des civils le greta delvina qui
propose notamment donc un crp agents de
sécurité avant de se quitter voyons
ensemble les rendez vous et qui vous
attendent vendredi 9 février la ville de
guyancourt organise un forum sur la voie
professionnelle s'est ouvert au public
de 17 heures à 20 heures
cela se déroule au pavillon pierre
waldeck rousseau plus de renseignements
au 01 30 48 33 99
et puis justement c'était le thème de
cette émission les métiers en uniforme
et bien ils seront à l'honneur mardi 13
février à la cité des métiers attrape ce
sera toute la journée de 9h 30 à 17
heures inscriptions au 01 34 83 82 61
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission à
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi 13 février pour un prochain mode
d'emploi consacré cette fois ci aux
métiers du développement web
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]